où
[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bon soit pas trop
d'accord mon gros nounours tu leur
montre le livre et moi je leur raconte
la suite des aventures du petit
cornichons bon le vol est homo popopopop
[Musique]
bonsoir mes choix ne poussez pas comme
ça voilà tu est posée et maintenant tu
nous montres la suite de l'histoire de
cornichons et du chant chez valve
d'attin avoue peu trop vous pouvez
raconter au bout patron ramoneur
ramoneur cri le petits cornichons qui
porte sur son dos une échelle une corde
et un balai il en fait un métier
gunn moustiques le ramoneur sont
toujours la grande dame maigre avec un
chignon maigre et pointue sur la tête
l'appel hier à mener ma cheminée quand
on échoue je te donne rue ou trois
français l'a toujours zimbra cornichons
monte sur le toit de la maison avec sa
corde et son balai il se met à ramoner
la cheminée quand tout à coup il entend
[Musique]
il trouve bien au chaud dans la cheminée
eu ni plein de bébés hirondelles avec
leur maman qui leur donne à manger
[Musique]
cris les petites hirondelles affolé
n'ayez pas peur leur dis cornichons et
ils nettoient la cheminée avec son
ballet tout doucement sans enlever le
joli nid qui restent bien au chaud
c'est gentil la truck long corps du show
avis
la maman hirondelles et si contente
qu'elle donne à cornichons une belle
pièce en or
andy dont il commence à trop riche il la
met soigneusement dans sa bouteille avec
les perles et le collier de coquillages
qu'il veut donner à sa maman puis il
monte sur la cheminée et regarde la
ville il n'y a pas beaucoup d'herbe dans
cette ville d'ada deviendra sûrement
jamais ici se dit notre petit garçon qui
commence à se sentir bien seul
et comme il a le coeur gros
il part loin de la ville dans la grande
forêt en pensant à sa maman à son papa à
la jolie musique qui lui jouait le soir
avant de s'endormir et à son grand ami
dada il va leur trouver bientôt bowie
parce qu'il est très malheureux très
bientôt vous gérez allons les enfants
l'histoire est finie vous a plu oui elle
est très jolie cette histoire merci
petit marchand de sable blond le petit
odon
[Musique]
là
justin lin bonheur
parallèlement le nov bonne nuit du cola
bonita prenait lé temps pierre bonelli
petit patronne elle bonne nuit petit
nicolas bonne nuit tous les enfants
allaient sagement vous coucher et faites
de beaux rêves
faute de bon mot bollock poteau alors en
route mon cher nounours dans la nuit à
demain à comme à bonn
[Musique]